der Krieg in der Ukraine er wütet weiter
die russischen Angriffe dauern an
es ist ein erbarmungsloser Krieg der
viele Menschen leben kostet es ist aber
auch ein Krieg der ohne Rücksicht auf
die Umwelt geführt wird
Chemiefabriken öldepots Industrieanlagen
Kraftwerke immer wieder sind sie das
Ziel von Kamikaze Drohnen und Raketen
die Folgen für die Natur dramatisch
ukrainische umweltinspektoren sind
erschüttert
was für ein Albtraum
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll wir
haben als ökologinnen schon viel gesehen
aber das ist das erste Mal dass wir es
mit solchen Zerstörungen zu tun haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine Stadt im Nordosten der Ukraine rund
100 km von der Front entfernt drei
umweltinspektoren schauen sich um an
einem Ort der wenige Monate zuvor Ziel
eines russischen Angriffs war
vieles nicht geblieben von dem
Einkaufszentrum das einmal hier stand
die größten Trümmer sind bereits
abgeräumt
Überwachungskameras haben festgehalten
was hier geschah
27 juni 2022 15 Uhr
das Einkaufszentrum ist gut besucht als
ein Marschflugkörper keine 50 Meter
entfernt einschlägt nach ukrainischen
Angaben werden 20 Menschen getötet eine
Fläche von rund 28000 Quadratmetern
steht entflammen es ist der bisher
schlimmste Angriff auf krementschuk
ein Ereignis das auch die staatlichen
umweltinspektoren bis heute nicht
loslässt so viele Menschen sind hier
gestorben und trotzdem müssen sie ihre
Arbeit tun
ist
wir haben hier einige Untersuchungen
gemacht
die Luft analysiert und man kann es sich
kaum vorstellen
allein aus diesem Einkaufszentrum sind
2200 Tonnen Schadstoffe entwickelt
das sind gewaltige Emissionen die in die
Atmosphäre gelangt sind und die sich
irgendwo auf der Erdoberfläche wieder
ablagern
nur wir Nutzer
im Auftrag des Staates dokumentieren die
Inspektoren Umweltschäden die durch den
Krieg verursacht werden sie sind
überzeugt dass das wichtig ist trotz des
menschlichen Leids und der
wirtschaftlichen Schäden die auf dem
Vordergrund stehen
das ist sehr wichtig denn ohne eine
intakte Umwelt ist auch das menschliche
Leben unmöglich jede dieser Explosion
bringt nicht nur den Tod sondern auch
gesundheitliche Schäden für die Menschen
die überlebt haben
internationale Umweltorganisationen
beobachten den Krieg in der Ukraine mit
großer Sorge im Fokus der Russen ist vor
allem die kritische Infrastruktur bis
dezember 2022 wurden über 1.100 Angriffe
auf mehr als 580 Ziele dokumentiert
dabei trifft es vor allem die
Schwerindustrie mit unabsehbaren Folgen
für die Umwelt
[Musik]
im niederländischen Utrecht beobachtet
man die Auswirkungen des ukrainekrieges
auf die Umwelt sehr genau
für die Friedensorganisation Pax
analysiert und verifiziert wem
swainenberg das Kriegsgeschehen
[Musik]
das ist das erste Mal seit langer Zeit
das in einem hochindustrialisierten
Landkrieg ist
die Ukraine verfügt über eine große
Bergbauindustrie aber auch viele
chemische Industrieanlagen im Westen des
Landes die angegriffen wurde
das birgt neue Risiken und erfordert
mehr Kapazitäten um diese potenziellen
Gefahren zu verstehen denn wir haben es
hier mit ernsthaften Risiken für
Menschen und Ökosysteme zu tun
Wimsbach wertet jeden Tag Berichte über
Kampfhandlungen aus in der Presse aber
auch in den sozialen Medien und er
überprüft diese mit Hilfe von
hochauflösenden Satellitenbildern er
will wissen was wirklich vor Ort
geschieht
hier sehen wir zum Beispiel ein
Wärmekraftwerk das getroffen wurde
das ist schwer beschädigt und die
hochauflösenden Bilder sind sehr
hilfreich um diese Schäden zu erkennen
neben den Schäden an der Anlage sehen
wir auch diese Tanks mit Schweröl die
getroffen wurden und man kann hier
ranzoomen wo das ganze Schweröl ausläuft
das gesamte Gebiet ist mit Schweröl
kontaminiert
alle Vorfälle werden dokumentiert und
gelistet die Datensammlung soll helfen
das Ausmaß der Schäden und ihre Folgen
abzuschätzen
[Musik]
das Risiko der Verschmutzung hängt davon
ab welche Art von Stoff ausläuft und
welche Menge
und dann schaut man wie die Menschen dem
ausgesetzt sind und wie die Ökosysteme
betroffen sein könnten
wird zunächst Öl verbrannt so dass die
Luft stark verschmutzt wird das ist ein
direktes Risiko für Menschen die in der
Nähe leben dann kann Öl auslaufen und
wenn es sich um eine beträchtliche Menge
handelt kann das das Grundwasser
verseuchen
besonders betroffen sind die umkämpften
Gebiete im Osten der Ukraine vielfach
ist hier noch gar nicht bekannt was
alles zerstört ist und welche Folgen das
auch für die Umwelt hat
an diesem Tag sind die ökologinnen
Tetyana kalimbett und Svetlana solonko
unterwegs nach apostologe einer kleinen
Stadt unweit der Front die immer wieder
unter Beschuss gerät
über 50 privater Häuser sind beschädigt
und zahlreiche öffentliche Gebäude
darunter auch diese Schule lange sah das
Militär die Lage in der Region als zu
gefährlich an an diesem Tag sind die
umweltinspektorinnen zum ersten Mal in
apostologe
was für ein Albtraum
man kann nicht einmal sagen wo hier mal
Flur oder Klassenzimmer waren ein Chaos
vor dem Krieg haben sie es mit kleineren
umweltdelikten zu tun gehabt
illegal entsorgter Müll ungereinigte
Abwässer und jetzt das
stellen Sie sich das nur vor die
Gemeinde hat mit ihrem eigenen Geld eine
wunderschöne moderne Schule gebaut und
jetzt sieht es hier so aus
unseren Kindern wird die Zukunft
genommen ganz abgesehen von den
Umweltschäden das zerstört jeden Glauben
an die Zukunft und Perspektiven für
unsere Kinder ich weiß gar nicht was ich
dazu sagen soll denn ehrlich gesagt sind
wir als ökologinnen oft losgezogen aber
dies ist das erste Mal dass wir solche
Zerstörungen sehen
es ist nicht die einzige Schule in
apostologe die es getroffen hat alle
drei Schulen im Ort sind zerstört auch
wenn Umweltschäden hier auf den ersten
Blick nicht das größte Problem zu sein
schein in den Ruinen lauern erhebliche
Risiken für Menschen und die Natur
hier könnte sich als beste befinden
außerdem Schwermetalle wir werden die
Proben auf zahlreiche Substanzen
untersuchen wir werden auf sulfate und
feste Rückstände analysieren und da ist
ein Dach mit Bitumenplatten geht werden
wir auch auf organische Lösungsmittel
testen
im Labor machen Sie sich gleich an die
Arbeit viele aus der Region sind
geflohen wegen der Angriffe und der
schwierigen Lebensbedingungen ohne Strom
Heizung oder Wasser
sie sind geblieben
das ganze Land arbeitet daran dass wir
weiter existieren leben und arbeiten
können und jeder hofft natürlich dass
das erfolgreich ist wir können jetzt
nicht alles fallen lassen und nichts tun
wir sehen uns hier als zweite Front
Odessa im Süden der Ukraine die
Hafenstadt am Schwarzen Meer ist immer
wieder das Ziel von russischen
Raketenangriffen und auch das Meer
selbst ist zum Kriegsschauplatz geworden
der Meeresbiologe Alexander kurakin
versucht zu dokumentieren was unter
Wasser geschieht doch das ist gar nicht
so einfach
ist das Tauchen natürlich mit gewissen
Schwierigkeiten verbunden an die Lage
auf den Gewässern sehr angespannt ist
kontrolliert das Meer und es gibt
überall wachen
dementsprechend können wir zurzeit viel
seltener tauchen als sonst
das heißt dieses Jahr hatten wir
wahrscheinlich nur 15 Tage die wir
draußen verbracht haben mit
früher hat kurakin jedes Jahr fünf
Monate auf dem Meer verbracht nun sind
weite Teile vermint und die Küste ist
zur Sperrzone geworden sogar für diesen
Tauchgang direkt am Ufer braucht er eine
Sondergenehmigung des Militärs
korakin nutzt jede Gelegenheit um zu
schauen welche Spuren der Krieg
hinterlässt sie haben das Land und das
Meer dürfen einfach nicht so schrecklich
geschädigt werden es ist klar dass
Spuren zurückbleiben werden und es ist
unsere Aufgabe die Größe dieser Spuren
zu bestimmen
[Musik]
seit Jahrzehnten erforscht und
dokumentiert kurakin die faszinierende
Unterwasserwelt der Schwarzen Meeres
Ökologen warnen schon lange denn die
einzigartige Tier und Pflanzenwelt unter
Wasser ist bereits stark bedroht durch
Industrieabwässer und Rückstände von
Düngemitteln
nun hinterlässt auch noch der Krieg hier
unten seine Spuren
Munitionsreste
Minen aber viel schlimmer noch sind die
Bedrohungen durch Öl aus Treibstofftanks
oder zerstörten Schiffen
wenn ein großes Kriegsschiff sinkt kommt
es zu einer gewaltigen Verschmutzung
es besteht die Gefahr einer nuklearen
Verseuchung
aber selbst wenn das nicht der Fall ist
es steigen solche Mengen an treib- und
Schmierstoffen auf dass sie sogar auf
Satellitenbildern sichtbar sind
das kann man vom Weltraum aus beobachten
es kann also kaum als kleines Problem
bezeichnet werden
und es ist unsere Aufgabe herauszufinden
wie schwerwiegend diese Probleme sind
Luftalarm in Odessa wie fast jeden Tag
Angriffe mit Drohnen und Raketen der
Strom ist ausgefallen in der Stadt auch
im Institut für Meeresbiologie hier
versuchen Sie herauszufinden wie der
Krieg das Meer verändert eine schwierige
Aufgabe unter diesen Verhältnissen die
Laborantinnen behelfen sich mit den
Taschenlampen ihrer Handys
[Musik]
nach solchen Angriffen gibt es oft ein
oder zwei Tage lang keinen Strom dann
wird die Versorgung meist wieder
hergestellt jeder kann hier seine
Geschichten erzählen wann man Strom hat
das kann um 3 Uhr nachts sein dann
stehen die Leute auf und arbeiten daran
hat man sich schon gewöhnt unsere
Arbeitszeiten hängen davon ab wann wir
Strom haben
weil sie zur Zeit kaum vor Ort Proben
nehmen können stützen sie ihre Analysen
vor allem auf Satellitenaufnahmen und da
sind es aktuell die Ölverschmutzungen
die sie mit großer Sorge beobachten
20.000 Quadratkilometer Wasserfläche
sind betroffen
das ist ungefähr die Hälfte der
Meeresfläche die zur Ukraine gehört
inklusive
alles Ölverschmutzungen die eine Folge
des Krieges sind
eine Katastrophe für das ohnehin
bedrohte Schwarze Meer zumal die
Verschmutzungen zur Zeit nicht
eingedämmt werden können wegen der Minen
und der ständigen Angriffe die Folgen
für die fragile Unterwasserwelt und auch
für die Anrainerstaaten sind derzeit
unabsehbar
[Musik]
in der Ukraine gibt es fast 50
Nationalparks und zahlreiche
Naturschutzgebiete laut dem ukrainischen
Ministerium für Umwelt wurden rund 30%
der geschützten Gebiete von den
russischen Truppen beschädigt oder
besetzt
in Hamburg untersucht ein Team der
Hochschule für angewandte Wissenschaften
die Auswirkungen des Krieges auf diese
sensiblen Zonen
ein Ökosystem ist ein sehr komplexes
System und der Krieg verändert das
Gleichgewicht
sorry
die größten Bedrohungen sind Brände
Raketenangriffe vermiete Gebiete und
militärische Bauten wie Schützengräben
und ähnliches
[Musik]
und verändern die Oberfläche
und es gibt militärische Abfälle
Landminen sind nicht nur in den
Naturschutzgebieten ein großes Problem
Ukrainer und Russen haben weite Teile
der umkämpften Gebiete vermiet die
Räumung ist mühsam
[Musik]
die Minen sind nicht nur eine direkte
tödliche Bedrohung für die Menschen
sondern auch eine Gefahr für die Umwelt
nicht explodierte Minen zersetzen sich
mit der Zeit und geben ihren explosiven
Inhalt in den Boden ab so können giftige
Chemikalien bis ins Grundwasser gelangen
die Ukraine beheimatet einzigartige
Naturschätze in den letzten Jahren
bemühte sich das Land diese natürlichen
Ressourcen zunehmend zu schützen
Maria federuk die selbst vor dem Krieg
in der Ukraine geflohen ist muss nun mit
ansehen wie erste Erfolge zunichte
gemacht werden
wir hatten in der Ukraine auch vor dem
Krieg eine Menge Probleme mit dem
Naturschutz das muss ich zugeben
aber wir haben die europäischen
Standards im Land vorangetrieben
und wir haben begonnen am europäischen
green Deal teilzunehmen und auch die
Prinzipien der Kreislaufwirtschaft
umzusetzen das hat sich sehr schnell
entwickelt
aber jetzt hat der Krieg das natürlich
dramatisch gebremst
Maria fedoruk und das Team der Hamburger
Hochschule sind immer wieder auch selbst
vor Ort um die Auswirkungen des Krieges
auf Naturreservate zu dokumentieren
es sind vor allem Waldbrände die
verheerende Schäden anrichten
ausgelöst meist durch Kampfhandlungen an
der Front
[Musik]
mykolajew im Süden der Ukraine lange
Zeit war die Region umkämpft dann haben
sich die russischen Truppen
zurückgezogen
die umweltinspektoren Jana mai-boroda
und kostantin sinkin schauen sich das an
was nach den Waldbränden übrig geblieben
ist Bäume stehen noch doch sie sind tot
[Musik]
lachen die Wälder hier lagen in der
Reichweite der konventionellen
Artillerie aber hauptsächlich wurde die
Gegend von mehrfach Raketenwerfern
beschossen
aufgrund des ständigen Beschusses
konnten die Förster und die Feuerwehren
nicht rechtzeitig auf Brände reagieren
die hier immer wieder ausbrachen
260 Hektar Wald sind zerstört die Bäume
waren bis zu 30 Jahre alt es wird
Jahrzehnte brauchen bis hier wieder
Wälder stehen
und Nikolajew ist nur eine der vielen
betroffenen Regionen
Satellitenbilder zeigen überall entlang
der ehemaligen und aktuellen Frontlinien
haben Wälder gebrannt oder Brennen noch
im April 2022 traf eine russische Rakete
die Regionalverwaltung in nicolaiw hier
hatten sie vor dem Ausbruch des Krieges
noch auf Tourismus gesetzt die
Schwarzmeerküste und Naturschutzgebiete
sollten europäische Besucher anziehen
nun geht es erstmal ums Aufräumen
wir müssen schnell loslegen weil es
lange dauern wird
aber wir werden uns sofort auf die
Umweltprobleme in unserer Region
konzentrieren
das ist uns sehr wichtig
und wir wissen dass es nicht in einem
Jahr behoben ist ihr eher desto besser
daher sollten wir gleich anfangen
und der Krieg ist noch lange nicht
vorbei im Oktober 2022 gab es einen
verheerenden Angriff die Folge eine
weitere Umweltkatastrophe direkt am
Hafen von Nikolai
hier wurden Tanks mit Sonnenblumenöl von
Kamikaze Drohnen getroffen
[Musik]
am 17 Oktober war das gesamte Gebiet
rund um das Depot im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes mit Öl überschwemmt das ganze
Gelände war voller Sonnenblumenöl
und auf der anderen Seite floss sehr
viel Öl in das regenwassernetz der
städtischen Kanalisation und von dort
weiter in die Mündung zum Schwarzen Meer
e tausend Tonnen Sonnenblumenöl wurden
freigesetzt ein Teil des Öls verbrennt
der Rest fließt in die Umgebung und in
den Hafen
der Feuerwehr gelingt es Öl von der
Wasseroberfläche abzupumpen
doch auch zwei Monate nach dem Angriff
finden Sie noch immer Reste im Wasser
und tote Tiere
die Inspektoren befürchten langfristige
Folgen für die Umwelt
bei den Fischen hatten wir zwar kein
Massensterben denn Fische fressen
Pflanzenöl
aber in einer so großen Menge kann es
ihre Fortpflanzungsfähigkeit
beeinträchtigen
wenn sich dieses Öl in den leicht
Gebieten der Fische absetzt wo sie ihre
Eier ablegen dann wird es keinen
Nachwuchs mehr geben
[Musik]
nie hätten Sie gedacht dass sie einmal
solche Umweltschäden dokumentieren
müssten mit einem Krieg hat hier lange
niemand gerechnet
natürlich versteht das keiner und
niemand konnte sich das Ausmaß eines
solchen Krieges auch nur vorstellen mit
wem wir auch immer darüber sprachen man
sagte uns das sei unmöglich wir haben
vier Kernkraftwerke es hieß einen
solchen Krieg werde es nicht geben
niemand werde das Zulassen leider waren
die Folgen bisher schon katastrophal und
der Krieg ist ja noch nicht vorbei wir
wissen nicht was wir noch alles zu
erwarten haben
tatsächlich ist die Gefahr die von den
Atomkraftwerken ausgeht erheblich
derzeit befinden sich im Land vier
Atomkraftwerke in Betrieb hinzu kommen
die stillgelegten Reaktoren von
Tschernobyl
[Musik]
im Sommer 2022 macht sich ein Team von
Greenpeace Deutschland auf dem Weg nach
Tschernobyl sie wollen herausfinden ob
es zu erhöhter Strahlung im Umfeld des
Reaktors kommt
schließlich hatte die russische Armee
gleich zu Beginn des Krieges dieses
Gebiet besetzt Messungen zeigen an
manchen Stellen erhöhte Radioaktivität
[Musik]
die radioaktiven Stoffe in der
tschernoby-zone die sind über die
Jahrzehnte im Boden in immer tieferen
stichschichten gebunden worden und durch
die Aktivitäten der russischen Armee
dadurch dass sie dort mit schweren mit
Panzern mit schweren LKWs durchgefahren
sind aber auch dadurch dass
Schützengräben ausgehoben worden sind
sind die radioaktiv gebundenen Stoffe
wieder mobilisiert worden das heißt sie
werden wieder in die in die Luft
gebracht in die Wassersysteme und
gefährden dadurch Mensch und Natur
in saporicia im Osten der Ukraine steht
Europas größtes Atomkraftwerk es ist
derzeit von russischen Truppen besetzt
und wurde bereits mehrfach beschossen
es ist direkt in der Kampfzone das heißt
die Gefahr dass die Reaktoren von
Granatfeuer von Bomben von Raketen
getroffen werden ist ist immens doch es
lauert noch eine ganz andere Gefahr
Russland greift gezielt das ukrainische
Energienetz an immer wieder kommt es zu
Stromausfällen im ganzen Land dabei sind
gerade Atomkraftwerke auf eine sichere
Stromversorgung angewiesen
Problem bei Atomkraftwerken ist hier sie
müssen ans Netz angeschlossen sein weil
sie brauchen beständig Strom um die
Kühlung aufrecht zu erhalten sowohl für
die Reaktoren selber als auch für die
abklingenbecken wo abgebrannte
Brennstäbe drin stehen wenn man diese
Kühlung nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten
kann dann kommt es auch zu einem
Super-GAU und zu Szenarien wie wir sie
in Fukushima oder auch in Tschernobyl
selber gesehen haben
das Kriege die Umwelt auf Jahrzehnte
schwer schädigen können hat sich immer
wieder gezeigt eines der prägendsten
Beispiele der Vietnamkrieg
in den 60er und 70er Jahren kämpfen die
USA auf der Seite Südvietnams gegen das
kommunistische Nordvietnam
Napalmbomben setzen Wälder und Dörfer in
Brand die US-Luftwaffe versprüht das
chemische Entlaubungsmittel Agent Orange
um Wälder zu lichten und Nutzpflanzen zu
vernichten
doch das darin enthaltene hochgiftige
Dioxin kontaminiert die Umwelt auf
Jahrzehnte
abgesehen von den Umweltschäden haben
wir in Vietnam auch gesehen dass
Menschen von Geburtsfehlern betroffen
waren schwangere Frauen waren dem Dioxin
im Boden ausgesetzt und es gab noch
viele andere gesundheitliche
Auswirkungen in den betroffenen
Gemeinden und das Gift wurde lange nicht
beseitigt
ein weiterer Fall der zweite Golfkrieg
1990 überfällt der Irak das benachbarte
Emirat
eine internationale Koalition unter
Führung der USA drängt die irakischen
Truppen zurück doch die hinterlassen
verbrannte Erde
sie setzten über 600 Ölfelder in Brand
diese branten über neun Monate lang das
führte zu einem Temperatursturz weil die
Sonne lange Zeit blockiert war und es
kam zu einer starken Verschmutzung des
Bodens und des meeresspruch
[Musik]
rund 240 Milliarden Liter Erdöl
verbrennen unkontrolliert das ist
ungefähr die doppelte Menge Rohöl die
jährlich in Deutschland verbraucht wird
der Internationale Gerichtshof
entscheidet der Irak muss kubait rund 50
Milliarden Dollar als Entschädigung für
Umweltschäden zahlen
der Fall qwait soll Vorbild sein so
sieht man das in der Ukraine
Russland soll für die Umweltschäden
haften daher werden Sie sehr genau
dokumentiert
ein öldepot bei Kiew es war bereits
dreimal das Ziel von russischen
Raketenangriffen 10 Tanks wurden
zerstört mehr als 12 Millionen Liter
Diesel und Benzin gingen in Flammen auf
über eine Million Liter Treibstoff
liefen aus
[Musik]
umweltinspektoren und Biologen versuchen
nun zu ermitteln welche Folgen die
Angriffe hatten sie gehen davon aus dass
über 40.000 Tonnen Schadstoffe in die
Luft ging darunter giftige Substanzen
wie Ammoniak Schwefeldioxid und
Schwermetalle
die Detonationen waren so heftig dass
sie offenbar auch das Schutzsystem
beschädigten das ein Einsickern von Öl
und Löschwasser in den Boden verhindern
soll
die ausgetretenen Flüssigkeiten
gelangten in die Umgebung und in den
Boden und wir müssen immer noch
verstehen und einschätzen wie viele
Ölprodukte oder ölprodukt Rückstände in
den Boden gelangt sind und bis in welche
Tiefe sie durch gesichert sind
die Umweltschäden durch die Angriffe auf
die öldepots schätzen sie allein hier
auf rund 40 Millionen Euro doch sie
wollen nicht nur Kosten beziffern es
geht auch darum die Schäden langfristig
zu beheben
an der Front kann ich im Moment nicht
viel tun ich bin kein Soldat ich kämpfe
doch nicht
deshalb versuche ich an anderer Stelle
etwas zu tun und ich weiß dass früher
oder später der Krieg vorbei sein wird
und wir alles wieder aufbauen müssen
die Umwelt muss revitalisiert saniert
wiederhergestellt erneuert werden
genau damit beschäftigen wir uns jetzt
aber wir haben noch keine Erfahrung wir
hatten so was bisher nicht es ist das
erste Mal für uns wir tappen da im
Dunkeln
die Ukraine beziffert die Umweltschäden
in den ersten elf Monaten des Krieges
auf 43 Milliarden Euro und noch herrscht
kein Frieden
doch eines ist sicher auch unter den
Umweltfolgen werden die Menschen in der
Ukraine noch Generationen zu leiden
haben
[Musik]